Tetris Tetris Tetris Tetris Tetris
the perfect game
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was the most beautiful thing I'd
ever seen
[Music]
I played for five minutes
still see falling blocks in my dreams
it's poetry art and math all working in
magical synchronicities
[Music]
it's the perfect game Tetris Tetris
Tetris Tetris Tetris I don't get it
It's a combination of tetra Greek for
four and tennis tennis the Martian
inventor he likes tennis
this game isn't just addictive it stays
with you this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity Hank only 10 other people in
the world have seen what you're about to
see
it's called The Game Boy packaging with
Tetris can you guess the rights
Soviet Union had worldwide rights
nothing gets out easily I'm gonna go to
Moscow you're walking into a country
they're still considers America enemy
Numero Uno okey dokey
sure you don't have to talk to your wife
about this first pioneers have to bet
the house to win but not literally
listen
have you ever heard our apartment this
quiet before
this is the inventor of Tetris your game
is brilliant I'm Gonna Make You A
Millionaire Mr Hodges have you ever
negotiated with the Soviets
we're here for Tetris
what do you say I don't speak Russian
the most powerful men in government
started watching you and your family do
you know where your husband is what the
hell is going on the world is changing
and Soviet Union will not be left behind
you want to play with the big boys this
is how the world Works where is my money
this is insane we can't protect you
sometimes you gotta forget you
[Music]
all right
this is Criminal
Soviet Union is about to implode they're
lying everybody Cavalry is coming we
don't have time I have a plan
oh come on you guys are the kings of
Cliffhangers
[Music]
foreign